you need to wait down
what's with the jeans I love him for the
narrowness of his jibs I love him for
the elegant lines of his gondola which
is now covered up for the winter oh boy
what's an amusement park ride yeah I've
seen this documentary this is a love of
inanimate objects yeah things um cars
just a fuck a ride at an amusement park
right and these people do put their
penis in yeah oh yeah I saw a
documentary guys this is a really big
amusement ride yeah he puts his penis
into a tailpipe how does this guy know
that it's a male rot he's like I love
him he's attributing gender for sure
yeah cuz what if that ride goes excuse
me I don't have a jib I don't know even
the names and names of the parts of
roller boy oh boy oh boy this guy has
something else yeah someone he should be
okay man yeah like it he's talking about
their damage what you think is down he
he hates humans he was so damaged he got
he got ya fingered on a ferris wheel
yeah you know yeah yeah there you go
his grandpa jacked him up on Ken man
grandpa grandpa was like you went goin
ferris wheel he's like yeah grandpa
there's grandpa Jack him off and he goes
don't fucking believe you and then and
then you gave him popcorn as I eat it
and then because he looks pretty heavy
and then he's like he's like I I want to
fuck all the roller coasters and he
really just needs to go kill his grandpa
right but do you think the popcorn made
the made the event pleasurable we don't
mean like a good got- but he made a
positive it was probably fun okay yeah
okay get though at the amusement that at
the parks is really a big thing
everybody loves it cuz it's hard it's
hard to come by a funnel right now
imagine you're getting finger blasted
right but then someone's feeding you
funnel cake right so it negates the it
negates the negative part of molestation
yeah no brother tastes in my mouth this
is good this is good yeah your Grandpa's
like
you grandpa's mr. white folks he's that
oh shit I love the way to the field
right now
I like the ribbing up underneath his
name display there too
oh yeah the parallel lines you use me
now it was just smacking oh I love that
he's so happy he looks he looks what
like somebody like somebody whispered in
his ear
you know like his grandpa is crazy I was
like I'm gonna make you condom we're
going for another ride and he's like
he's so heroes you literally just looked
up and giggled at the roller coaster
like they had a connection it's like
it's so we just laughing so I'm thinking
oh jeez you know what I'm thinking about
this is very personal when I make love
to him at home when I start climaxing oh
my god
I just keep saying over and over again
just as I'm starting to go over the edge
I just tell them I want your fluids
I want your fluids I want your food